thank you burner
good afternoon and welcome to this
northwestern area planning committee
meeting on Monday the 8th of June 2020
my name is Council and this is Maggie
Thompson under chairman of this
committee this is more than District
Council's first remote area planning
committee meeting held under new
regulations which came into effect on
4th of April in response to the Kovach
19 situation there are just a few
housekeeping rules issues to run through
including our new working practices
which have been implemented due to the
pandemic and the etiquette for this
meeting first of all could I please ask
everyone present in this meeting to
ensure your microphone remains muted and
the video feed off we're not actually
addressing the committee this will
reduce background voices and avoid any
unintentional disturbances the meeting
is hosted which allows members of the
public to virtually attend the meeting
what's being able to protect themselves
and others and observe the government's
not found measures you may encounter
some ditches this afternoon so I hope
that everyone will bear with us as we
get used to this new way of working
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded members and
officers during each item please use the
chat function of the meeting to indicate
if you wish to speak I will then invite
you all at the appropriate time members
are reminded that apart from indicating
your wish to speak or that you have to
leave the meeting the chat function
should not be used for any other purpose
members the process this afternoon will
obviously be different and for some
items I may invite each member to speak
in turn therefore I would encourage all
members to keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible please
when speaking and referring to agenda
papers please ensure you reference a
page or paragraph number could I also
ensure that everyone is directly
connected to a power supply so that no
one drops out to some short battery life
and lastly members if you need to leave
a meeting at any point please make this
known and use the chat function to
signify and excuse me that means
now I'm going to ask the officers taking
part in the meeting to introduce
themselves starting with mr. Li good
afternoon members and members of public
I am Matthew Lee and I am lead
specialist place here at modern District
Council thank you and now mr. Johnson
good afternoon everyone my name is
Michael Johnson I am the lead specialist
development management thank you thank
you and mr. Turner good afternoon
everybody my name is Devin Hana and I'm
a specialist in development management
that modern Council thank you thank you
and good afternoon I'm Hannah Bowles and
I'm a specialist in development
management was Parker Haynes good
afternoon I'm hailey Parker Haynes and
I'm a senior caseworker in development
management thank you
do we have Miss Matthews or we do have
this white button council white button
the way I've noticed do we have hello
Catherine your of your headsets up so
you need to lower it so we can hear your
voice okay see committee services and
Clark to the meeting this afternoon
thank you
parlor any other officers present who I
haven't mentioned attendance German yes
and councillor Bamford sorry could you
just unmute and um Thank You president
Thank You councillor Durham present
master Fleming present office present
it's the keys councillor keys thank you
Sydal here counselor mrs. Thompson oh
definitely
miss white yes I'm here
thank you and apologies for absence
please Berner we've received apologies
for absence from councillor morning
thank you
right item three on the agenda members
is the minutes of third of February it
does seem awfully long time ago I am
going to take them as read if anyone
does need time to read them please let
me know on the chat function it is
recommended the minutes of the meeting
held on 3rd of February found on pages 9
- 14 are approved there's a true of
accurate as a true and accurate record I
so move if you wish to second that
motion please just turn on your video
and unmute your microphone state your
name now and if any member wishes to
raise any matter of accuracy please use
the chat function to indicate and I were
invited to speak agreed Thank You
members we could do the roll call and
and vote but does anyone to have any
matters of accuracy to raise is there
any I'd rather do this by descent
because that's the simple way because
any member wish to speak I'll give you
three seconds then I will take those
minutes as agreed thank you very much
members right moving on item four
declarations of interest this I have to
read if I always do to disclose the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interests other pecuniary
interests or non pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph six to
eight inclusive of the code of conduct
for members members are reminded they're
also required to disclose any such
interest as soon as they become aware
should the need arise during the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat button function to
indicate now I can see you counselor
dharam I suppose expected thank you as a
member of Essex County Council and non
pecuniary interest as they are statutory
consultation a number of planning
matters thank you thank you is there
anyone else there's not really anything
happening on the chat I'm keeping an eye
on it chairman we have councillor
Fleming councillor Jarvis and councillor
Sydal wishing to declare an interest is
there a reason they're not appearing on
my chart at dish they're on the meeting
chat I just need to I'd probably just
need to add them to the other chat as
well yes I don't be looking at the right
chat can you bear with me members just
for a second so Fleming is the first I
can't get on the chat either councillor
case
mr. Jarvis and counselor sidled fast and
Dan counsel we take counselor keys
that's the meeting chat that should be
on your right if you click on your on
the menu if you click on the little
speech bubble its fence next with two
participants but I'm sending you a
message now on this with Josh line that
we set off the sly I've gotcha
thank you so let's count the fleming
castle and NGB counselor keys okay well
I do my counselor job is first on the
list so so we got me that first please
classroom Thank You chairman have a
kidney interest item six land adjacent
to Grange Road okay thank you so you'll
be leaving a meeting I think that's
correct yes yes thank you if you can let
us know on the chat when you are leaving
and also anything that again when you
come back
agenda item 8 I know the family the
applicants in the past as rented afar
and the applicants brother is our
bailing contractor so there is a
financial relationship there so I feel
that I should leave the meeting and not
beg for that item indicate on the track
when you've left and when you return
houses little things yeah I'd like to
declare a non key no interest on item
number five plays with house 25 Plains
Road I know the applicant and I have
bought things from his shop okay thank
you
I think right counselor white and then I
think counsel please tell us right
I have to leave early I will let you
know previous time okay right are we
concluded with the declarations of
interest members okay then I think we
will move on to item 5 which is our
first planning application its planes
would house 25 planes road great Totten
I'll start off by saying I will be
moving all the opposite recommendations
which does not indicate that I support
or otherwise I won't make a decision to
live hurt the whole of the debate but we
do need a motion on the table so I would
be grateful if on the same basis someone
would second all those when we come to
them right I've said 25 planes
Road I'm going to ask the officer to
present this item and the sorry the
presentation is being shared on your
screen so concerning can you please
present your report Thanks
Thank You chairman detached outbuilding
which contains carriages gymnasium and a
garden room and there's also storage
rooms in the roof space which is served
by a dormer windows the location plan
and you can see this site is to the
north of Plains Road this is the block
plan so this is the building that
relates to the application it's worth
noting that planning permission was
previously granted for the out building
but - the dormer windows that you can
see here and the first floor storage
space and this were granted on the temp
for January in 2019 as it's the
intention to provide the storage space
at the same time as the remainder of the
development then it's considered that
the use of the first floor space as
storage as well as as well as the
provision of the dormer windows requires
planning permission here we have the
proposed elevations where you can see
the sighting of the dormer windows and
the floor and roof plans so this is the
storage space I'm referring to just for
reference these are the previously
approved elevations you can just see the
differences that the dormer windows
don't appear and the previously approved
floor and roof plans there's no first
floor storage base space here we have
photos at the front of the site and also
the street scene is from within the site
so although there's a concern that the
first floor roof space could be used as
residential accommodation in the future
because the building is located in the
residential curtilage and a conditional
conditions are a similar to the one
imposed on the 2019 permission which
prevented the use of the building for
purposes that are not and celebrit
ancillary to the residential use that
the host willing could be imposed it's
considered that this building could also
be managed by a suitably worded
condition however the concern is that
the number of the dormer windows
proposed and the size and the extent of
the building the resultant development
would appear more residential in
character than this is subservient
outbuilding also the dormer windows
would add a new architectural feature to
their building and which would erode its
relationship between both the dwelling
and the outbuilding there's also
glimpses of the dormers are available
from within the lane road and the
neighboring properties so it's
considered that there would be
demonstrable harm to character and
appearance of the site and the rural
area and for that reason the application
is recommended for a refusal Thank You
chairman thank you there's no one to
speak on this so as I said sacred
correctness I'm going to put the
recommendation that the application is
refused for the reasons as detailed in
section 8 of this report is that second
okay second proposed well you have a
proposal see what happens with the
recommendation but as I say we're only
putting this on the table we're not
committing ourselves to support it or
not
so are we go as to you actually don't
agree with the councilors recommendation
you certainly can't say that I'd say why
we need a bit more widened I call the
proposal e and I called the house in
that's why I've called the Garrity nor
the gymnasium and I think the dormer
windows do add a bit of character and
they only look over the house and has
been stated in the letter I think we've
all seen that was put out it's in the
curtilage of the building it couldn't be
separated you know there was no gap
between the house and
the garage significant enough for it to
be a second dwelling I think and I think
it should be pass you know it just
enhances this a large house in a large
plot okay thank you
Council of wise things yeah I mean I
have to say I supported this outbuilding
when it first came up last year it
doesn't have a problem with it and I
actually think that in a house that size
they wouldn't want the garage a few feet
from their back door sold off to another
person so I don't think I can't see
strange neighbors outside the back door
into a separate dwelling I'm sure
they'll be happy to put a condition on
it that it can't be a separate dwelling
and so I'm I actually do not agree with
the officers recommendation and I'd like
to see second proposal to approve it
okay well we do have to go through the
through the form of voting for the
proposal that's on the table so we'll do
that and if it fails we'll come to
council cases also Jarvis please I think
I'd just like to echo what's just been
said by councilor wide I mean
architecture er the fact that there
aren't dormer windows on the house yeah
I think is irrelevant
I think the dormer windows fit in
architecture II absolutely fine with the
overall sort of look and feel of it it's
a large building obviously which has
been improved before I just I don't
think objecting because of the dormer
windows stands stands up to scrutiny so
I'm certainly not not in favor of I
think the proposal on the table thank
you anyone else right I will put the
proposal on the table and we'll those
asking earner to take a roll call sorry
sorry if I'm falling over my teeth this
is the first time I've done this as long
as everyone has confirmed the counter
BAMF and I can see you are you proventil
did you want to speak I would like to
just confirm page 19 the the relevant
history is definitely for this property
because there was another property
listed so I just want you to clarify
that thank you
um can we go to the case officer on that
one please that's for you chairman yeh
apologies counselor Bank that's correct
that's the wrong address is listed just
badly one moment just checking with it's
just a typographical error so it's 2 km
the the history that's listed is correct
but unfortunately the reference at the
top that relates to east cottage is
incorrect so apologies for that but that
is the correct planning history for this
application site okay thank you
Thanks
roll call thank you chair I'll take
members through in alphabetical order
and if you can state clearly for against
or abstain councillor Bamford bearing in
mind is like the recommendation to
refuse thank you so this is the this is
in accordance with the officers
recommendation this I'm round out okay
I'm for Jam sorry to say Durham yes I
did you agree agree officers
recommendation as a damn castle mrs.
Fleming against the officers
recommendation others
against is against the officers
recommendation counselor Siddle against
Haslam mrs. Thompson I'm staining a
Little Miss white against okay thank you
very much gonna I was keeping counts or
I'm correct and confirm on correctly
yes it's 2 for 4 against and 1
abstention okay thank but we have an out
proposal to approve the application from
counsel please but we need reasons for
approval and we need to agree any
conditions that we wish to impose and I
will also look to the case officer
and/or mr. Lee and/or mr. Johnson to
give us an indication of conditions they
think would be appropriate so counselor
keys why do you think about your please
go to whichever officer I I should
oh and counselor counselor Jarvis also
wishes to comment but can we start with
Thank You chairman obviously
applications were expected in nature so
there is no need for the time condition
that we would normally impose if members
are to look to prove the scheme I would
recommend that conditions should include
plans materials also immolation to
obscure glazing for the dormers because
obviously it's for storage so that won't
be an impact on future living conditions
and would protect amenity and as the
officer said in a presentation we would
recommend a condition in relation to the
building to be used and ancillary to the
main dwelling thank you chairman and
councillor Jarvis you wish to speak was
that
well I was just happy to second cancel
the keys regarding the conditions the
axillary condition seems sensible or is
this good
could somebody comment as to whether its
normals how a condition to have sort of
obscure glass that seems a bit excessive
exactly is that usual mr. Ling please be
chairman each application is determined
on its own merits and the conditions
that should be imposed need to fit the
application before us as members
understand from the plans this property
has a side-on relationship both with the
amenity of the existing property and
also the site to adjacent to it so I
would advise that members should look to
protect the overlooking potential
overlooking take into account obviously
that this is a store area so there
wouldn't be any harm to anybody for
impact on living conditions or anything
like that
Thank You chairman thank you for no
permission to use as presidential and
that was listed by mr. Lucas thank
chairman the condition in relation to a
distillery use would mean they wouldn't
be able to be used as an independent
dwelling without the need for planning
permission it could be used for Nanak's
if members had concerns in relation to
that we could impose a condition that
restricted that as well Thank You
chairman right I'm going to turn to
councillor keys on that one please if
you could give us some indication of
your reasons for wanting to approve it
and whether you accept the conditions as
set out if not would you like to add or
remove any of them and then once we have
a everything a list of everything we can
have a bulk company that's a queen
it's not proposal hello counselor keys
oh right while we waited the council
appease and helps us it all has a
comment oh we can hear you now but I
have also got counsels signal to comment
but let's have your proposal and then
we'll have pencils doodles comments so
you can hear me now here you know got my
mobile phone next minutes come up with
some comment about mobile as well but
anyway I think the the exhibit of the
darkened glass is that really needed you
know with if he's going to use save
using artificial light we've got the
daughter so we can have proper light you
know external lights as long as it's
included in the dwelling of the
footprint of the house the dormers only
look over the house so I can't see
there's a problem while we've got have
obscured glazing and that's only more
what I would come up with you know and
if they want to use it as an annex as
long as it's in the footprint of the
building and it can't be sold away which
I think we've all commented it's too
close and with someone with a load of
phrase with someone we've bought a house
like that want to sell the place away I
think we all know the answer to that
question ok thank you so you accept some
suggested conditions with the exception
of the obscure those glass as long as it
couldn't be sold away I cannot see a
problem with that some oh hey how about
a reason to approve the reason for
refusal so do you think it is not words
in your mouth you don't think it is oh
no sir only don't know you drive down
there you I think you if you drive down
the road you see the Hat you see the
house before the garage and if you drive
up blinds right
you see the house before the garage I
can't see it's detrimental to the to
place at all I can't I can't see where
that's come from but that's my personal
opinion the house certainly comes into
focus coming from either ways up the
road and even if you come down the road
by the golf course with speck on the
road or making a robot a golf course you
see the house before the garage anyway
so I don't see where that's come from
but that's my personal opinion
okay thank you mr. Lee is that something
you can work with yeah three chairman I
would summarize councilor keys point
that he doesn't consider that the first
development has a strong visual impact
on the character the surrounding area
and his limit views in the public realm
and therefore the alterations of the
provision of dormers are not have a
detrimental impact such as it be as to
what reason for a few but we have a
comment from Council Sydal and followed
by councilor proposal Thank You chairman
yeah I'd just like to add that we need
to ensure that it is just for ancillary
use and that I don't see the need for
obscure glass because it doesn't really
overlook any surrounding properties okay
thank you well we've now lost that from
the proposal anyway because council keys
didn't include that so we're with you so
far and Kelter Bamford please
Thank You chairman sorry I know I know
that I voted against the proposal to
approve this anyway but I do think that
it should be restricted from being used
as an annex as well and I know others
have said they don't need obscure
glazing but if it's for storage then I
don't see why it shouldn't have obscure
glazing because why would they need to
see out particularly so well that's just
my points but I mean it's already been
approved by most councillors anyway I
think we can see the way that's going I
mean you can put that as an amendment to
the proposal that's already being made
to not include but which doesn't include
the excuse but I think we can see our
members feel about that but that's
entirely up to you on an amendment
including the excuse after all please do
yes I would like to include obscure
glass and not using it as an annex but I
think from what I gather from others
they've already accepted that that is
fine so I don't see my amendments going
to make a lot of difference but if you
need to vote on it then fine well if
you'd like an amendment to be voted on
and you can get a second there is anyone
prepared to second councilor Bamford's
amendment of having them having a
conditional obscured glass and also I'm
quite sure not using it as an annex and
I have councillor white who says he
wouldn't want obscure windows in the gym
but the gym isn't upstairs Downstairs
windows and house the Jarvis wishes to
speak so does councillor ban could have
a seconder her for her amendment speak
now forever hold your peace
and mr. Lee is actually typing you can
speak mr. Lee's so I teach and I think
the case officer wanted to raise a point
there but her no thank Jim absolutely
sorry right so can I confirm with use
case office of the upstairs we are only
talking about storage it's a lot yes
thank you right we have a second
Amendment but also have consul Jarvis
wishes wishing to speak again we need to
get on with some of this voting so if we
could just have councillor Jarvis and
then move on to voting on the amendment
yeah Thank You chairman I think my point
my reason was sort of missing normal
glass if I can put it that way is up
they've obviously got tumors because
they may work want at some point to use
it as an annex and I think I was quite
reasonable and obviously they would want
normal glass if that was to be the case
so I think it really goes I think if
they were just going to use it for
storage frankly they probably probably
wouldn't need dormice so I think they
keep watching for the future I think
that's yeah actually quite reasonable so
but I don't wish to I think you've got a
seconder for that amendment
sorry mr. Lee proposal they would be
permission to use this as an annex
through Chairman it's a bit of an
interesting one because at the moment if
they wouldn't if they were to build it
like this however in the future if they
were to do work that was considered to
not be development therefore internal
works as long as it was used as an annex
that would still be an Silurian
therefore wouldn't require a plan of
admission but I said if they were to
build it straight out as an annexed and
actually that would be a breach control
because that isn't what they have
applied for thank you chairman
okay so just to
confirming they
if permission is given and at some point
in the future they decided to put a
spare bed in there that would not be a
breach of plan control yeah that is
correct chairman if we don't put on a
condition then it can't be right to keep
things systemic we have to vote on
council Bamford's amendment to include
school eighth grade class because we've
already established that it will be in
the end ciliary youth perhaps the keys
has commented that clear windows save on
artificial light and but if you're only
scoring things up there you probably
don't need them however chairman for
point of clarity obscure glazing is not
mean they're blacked out so they would
still go to get light in there is a
difference obviously we're talking about
yeah that's correct think okay right
those in favor
council abandons backwards amendment and
please indicate as burna calls the roll
function german and i just say i want
you to come back on this point about not
having it as an annex that the whole
point of this this planning application
was is retrospective it was for storage
in the roof space it was never meant to
have windows and they're not holy and we
have now been asked to agree something
that wasn't originally planned and i i
that's the reason why i don't agree with
this application you know if they'd have
wanted in our necks they should have
applied for it they did not do that and
i'm not happy with agreeing having
windows or glazing that's clear or that
they have permission to use it as an
annex they didn't want that that's not
what they asked for originally i thank
you and if we're calling i'm voting for
my amendment okay thank you i burn if
you could completely things okay so good
counselor Banford is for casler durham
for
I mean for this is only on the amendment
no no not yes not bad policy we're we're
looking at amending the proposal
councillor Jarvis against peas cancer
Gainey's against sorry counselor keys
you said there go cancerous it'll
against Council mrs. Thompson
I'm staying
until miss white against okay could you
give me the numbers please burner three
for three against and one abstention
oh sorry constant miss wash was sorry
customers fight for your vote once again
again it's against against okay sorry
three four four against and one
abstention okay the so the amendment
fails and the substantive motion remains
counsel please proposal which is to
approve because on the grounds that
there is no well mr. Lee phrased it
perfectly but basically there is no
impact on the community and to include
all the conditions outlined by mister
new but not obscure class is that still
all right with you council includes call
the roll on the voting that I store
against or abstaining please on what's
new substantive them vote motion to
approve Banford councillor Bamford Cory
against Durham against Fleming against
now sir Jarvis for the keys for after
sigil for us mrs. Thompson abstain the
miss white Oh
that sounds like four three no that's
three four three against one you're
breaking up a little bit that's you will
marry that is three three counselors
four three counselors against right and
one abstention we seem to be sorry it is
for counselors for because I'm sorry I
have a custom orally in the mix that's
for Tom three against and one abstention
so that's that House passes and
permission is approved as we all
previously discussed is that everyone
felt as clear as mud okay thank you
right moving on then we have gender
rights and six Lander grace adjacent to
two grains Road within bishops in a
moment I'll call on the officer to
present the item members a reminder if
you wish to speak please make this known
using the chat function I will come to
you in turn this is miss Bowles could
you please present your report thank you
thank you care outline planning
permission with matters of access and
layout for the termination is sought for
the demolition of the existing buildings
and structures and the erection of one
detached dwelling we have the location
plan the block plan the existing
elevations of the former pigsty the
existing floor and roof plans of this
warmer pigsty the existing elevations
floor and roof plans of the storage
building indicative floor plans and
indicative illustration as the
appearance and scowl are matters which
are reserved and then we have
photographs of the sigh
so the proposed development is a
departure from the local plan however an
identical scheme has been approved
initially in 2013 and again in 2016
there have been no significant changes
to the site or surrounding area and
whilst the current LDB has been approved
since the determination of the 2016
application the change in policy
position is not considered to outweigh
the planning history of the site
therefore is considered it will be
unreasonable to reject to the principle
of the dwelling further it is considered
that the site can provide adequate
parking provision and private amenities
fail and the dwelling could be provided
which would not negatively impact the
occupiers of the neighboring dwellings
therefore the application is recommended
for approval thank you
thank you chairman I support the
officers recommendation and I think
everybody can see the photographs that
are in the pack don't bear much relation
to the to the floor plans the floor
plans actually make it look rather
better condition than they actually are
so in line with the previous decisions I
support the officers recommendation
thank you thank you
I didn't in fact put the officers
recommendation take you as a seconder
for that place you may chairman I should
have declared an interest on this one
that I do know the applicant okay
non-pecuniary okay thank you did you
does anyone wish
anyone else wish to speak otherwise I'm
gonna put the motion to what I have put
the motion to approve I'm going to vote
on the motion to approve in line with
the officers recommendation this
approach to pass or reject
recommendations keys the officers
recommendation is that be of it be
approved subject to assign unilateral
undertaking and all sorts of other stuff
but that's the officers recommendation
is to approve with conditions well this
this is just an application that has
been in before isn't it I think
something along those lines okay thank
you
right so Donna could you just quickly
run through the roll cut roll call yes
of course and councillor Bamford gore so
Darren Reed as Denise Fleming for pass
the keys for
Sydal for mr. Thompson Oh for okay that
sounds like a full house thank you thank
you
item six to land adjacent to grains row
this is approved in line with the
officers recommendation okay right
moving on to the barn
this is item 7 agricultural bonds
adjacent to 31 Plains Road in a moment
I'm going to ask the officer to present
the item there is a submission from the
agent which as the chairman of the
Council said the other day he I consider
can be read in two minutes so if I fail
to read it in two minutes that's my
fault not the agents probably haven't
practiced as well
so thank miss Boles could we have your
presentation please thank you care
planning permission is sought for the
demolition of the existing outbuildings
and construction of two detached
residential dwellings here we have the
location plan the block plan and the
parking plan and the existing elevations
of the buildings on site and the
existing floor plans but the proposed
elevations for the plot one which is on
the western side of the site and the
proposed floor plans have the proposed
elevations for plot 2 which is on the
eastern side of the site and the
proposed floor plans the existing and
proposed streets team got the right
photos the existing buildings proposed
to be demolished are currently in an
employment generating use and it has not
been demonstrated that there isn't a
demand for the employment use the
application site lies outside of the
settlement boundary its remote from
community support facilities and public
transport and would result in an
unwelcome visual intrusion whilst the
proposed dwellings would replace
existing buildings the current built
form is former agricultural buildings
which are reflected of reflective of the
rural area therefore the proposal is
recommended for refusal thank you thank
you is back and has been present since
the beginning of this I need to read
this submission I will do my very best
not to fall over my own teeth and this
is of course the agents views and I'm
merely reading it good afternoon members
my name is I am a chartered town planner
speaking to you on behalf of the
applicant of his scheme
having seen the site or the place
offices photos at the site members would
have noticed that the application site
comprised
a number of old and tired agricultural
buildings these buildings are of know I
could architectural merit and do not
positively contribute to the countryside
skiing proposes to remove these
unattractive buildings and replace the
two houses that I feel match the pattern
and also proposes to restore a large
area to the rear of the site's work and
countryside which would have a positive
impact members would have noticed from
the officer's report that in summary the
officer leveled objection to the
proposed development relates to the
site's location within the countryside
and loss of employment the pace offices
reason for refusal to not relate to harm
to neighboring amenity parking or
highway matters as noted within the
officer's report the application site
has an existing unrestricted lawful use
as a v8 storage or distribution center
this lawful use is a material planning
consideration as the site can be
operated much more intensively than it
currently is a public consultation event
was held to assess the community feeling
towards the scheme prior to the
submission of this application as
members would have noted from the
statement of community involvement that
supported the application the majority
of residents supported the scheme and
noted that they would prefer to see a
sensitive major residential scheme
rather than the existing law for the
innocent buildings to remain National
Planning Policy same framework
recognises the opportunities the
maximized sustainable transport solution
will vary between urban and rural areas
we acknowledge that the proposal would
lead to some reliance on the private car
however this is not untypical of a
semi-rural location and this is
recognized by the framework and also
like to highlight that the same
framework recognizes the intrinsic
character and beauty of the countryside
but does not seek to protect this per se
with protection in quotes being a term
now only applied to designated areas and
other valued landscapes which get
application site does not fall within
the mere fact that the application site
lies outside a define development
boundary does not therefore
automatically render the site
sustainable the proposed dwellings have
been designed to be in keeping with
dwellings directly to the east and south
of the site and this again follows
comments received at the public
consultation event where and they
new housing should be similar size style
and design to make sure there are these
properties would not be undermined the
economic development benefits arising
from the scheme including temporary
employment generic construction and
additional spending within the village
as well as tax receipts for the parish
of district council also worth noting in
these current difficult economic times
finally about the lack of a legal
agreement to secure Rams payment has not
been raised as an issue during the
determination of the application and
this could easily have been overcome I
can however confirm that should members
being supportive this scheme the
relevant payment will be made prior to
the issuing of decision as anyone we
believe this is a positive application
not only because it would support the
local economy but because it would
positively contribute towards the
landscape character of the area and
residential amenity we hope members can
see the many benefits of the proposal
and thank you for your consideration
[Music]
sorry the recommendation which I am
putting and I'm looking for a seconder
please is that the application for the
agricultural bonds adjacent to 31 Plains
Road be refused for the reasons detailed
in section 8 of this report do I have a
seconder failing that members would like
to comment I call this in chairman so
can I comment first Thank You chairman
this particular site has had quite a
long history in terms of the village and
in terms of different applications and
these buildings have no benefit at all
to the village and haven't been used for
an awful long time and as the my video
keeps stopping you can hear me still
they Kearney we can hear you fine if it
helps to switch the video off and carry
on just voice
so yes they in terms of urbanizing you
can get more urban dan what's there at
the moment it is a brownfield site and
it's just a slight extension of the
houses that are already there so as the
sort of the report says there are there
is going to be an effect it is a rural
area however the countryside doesn't
start until after these buildings and as
part of the application which is why
quite like about it is they are going to
restore some of the countryside at the
bottom of the the new houses the
development in terms of 3.2.1
it's no denser than it is at the moment
those houses are going to be on large
plots and I think that it will be
reflective of the area and it will
enhance the character of this part of
the village in five point one point four
it states that the countryside will be
impacted it won't be because this site
has already got buildings on it so
therefore when you look at the streets
it's going to be it's going to look
better too then what's there at the
moment in five point one point eight the
the information that's provided there
applies to all other houses on Plains
Road it applies to the development the
bridges to prove the in terms of the the
annex on five point one point eleven
this building is is derelict and if you
were to restore and if it were to use
for business and if it was used for
storage and distribution which is what
one of the applications
yeah that it has I think that would have
a bigger effect on total north than if
it's converted into houses and would
have a bigger effect in terms of
transport there is a public transport in
this area but that would also apply to a
business that's using it there is a
public transport to take people to work
there those buildings on
five point four point nine they add no
quality to the surroundings in terms of
five point eight even if it was turned
into a business the wildlife part would
also need to be looked at so one of the
conditions I would this goes ahead that
we do have a full wildlife survey but
also as part of the development that we
have back boxes and our box is installed
so I am in I'm against the officers
recommendation and I think that we
should approve this application names
down and I'm very sorry it isn't but I
have councillor white house Allah
Bamford then councillor keys all then
councillor Darren so could we please
start with Celts are white and then go
on through council white please thank
you madam chairman I mean I'm mindful
this should be approved because
basically the buildings are not fit the
purpose
you couldn't rent them out for business
use because they look to me like they're
falling down and then it would probably
be an economical to rebuild them and
also think that two house would be an
improvement on the seat streams street
scene to the falling down buildings that
were there and I think they have no use
to rent out whatsoever they're too
dilapidated so I'd like to second
councillor city's proposal thank you
well we can't do that we're still on the
recommendation Thank You mr. chairman
for point for point of clarity just as
you like so FC the council's policy does
allow for lots of employment one it's
being appropriately evidenced and I do
know the comments that have been made by
members the issue of the offices have is
it's not considered that there's any
been any substantive argument in
relation to that put forward by the
applicant I'll just lovely like to
highlight concerns from an officer
perspective if members were to make want
better word assumptions based on the
appearance of the buildings that they
aren't economically viable you know this
should be supported by appropriate
evidence and
if that was to come forward that reason
defuser would fall away but I just want
to highlight that I do advise members to
remember what the policy requires and
obviously as the office report explains
this hasn't been provided as part of
this application and members shouldn't
base recommendations or decisions on
assumptions Thank You chairman v-8
storage and distribution is a current
lawful use does that mean subject to
design requirements etc that is a
material consideration in an application
to rebuild the bounds for that use or we
build a building for that use food
chairman obviously the local use of the
site would be a material consideration
obviously if a new application was to
come in we would consider all the
various matters as always so we'd also
be interested in protecting the amenity
would probably put understanding
conditions about non external works
etcetera but that's obviously very was
something she without any application I
can't really comment I think it's a
couple of questions as well as some
something I would like to see the
existing street scene and the proposed
street scene again if I may I also
wanted to ask if we have a highways
update because there wasn't any comments
from highways in the report and I also
didn't see a lot of information about
the community involvement which was
referred to in the agents report that
was read out by the chairman would this
community involvement be a material
consideration in looking at this because
if the majority of the community think
it's fine
is that something we should consider
three Chairman I can pick up that point
so it sent no case law is quite clear
that the support or lack of support for
a planning application in principle on
its own is not a material consideration
for the termination of a planning
application an application must be
determined on the don't plan on material
considerations indicate otherwise
obviously if members of public bodies
points that are material considerations
they are a consideration but the level
of support in favor or against
application per se on its own is not a
material situation that should be
attributed way thank chairman I'm not
sure they'd even comment on roads like
that well if we're going to approve it
we need to know what the highways would
say would we're at the moment we're
debating refusing it a nine with the
officers recommendation so shall we see
how that goes and let the case officer
look it up if need anything in the
meantime thank you
I think councillor white the cast the
keys and councillor Durham I think right
councillor wide not reading the wrong
bit of chat all right I think I think
I've already into my reasons and I still
think that whether a reports being done
or not I still think the report that the
buildings like they're falling down is
very relevant I did Drive past there and
have a look and I think this should be a
material consideration and you know for
it okay thank you
council case oh I'm very pleased my
fellow board member is in agreement to
disagree with the council on this
because I think anybody's saying this is
capable of being used for distribution
center storage the place is falling a
bit and what would the highway when it
was a farm I remember as a farm
Laura's come back in there 24 hours a
day seven days a week it was a peak farm
so I don't really think the highways
he's on a junction
as a junction coming down from Beckenham
Road next door to a big hat or next door
bangle oh that's now next order of big
house which we have just passed
permission for a garage I think it just
improves the street scene and it will be
a credit to the area because it will
tidy up that mess and that's all I've
gotta say thank you thank you not them
not without technical expertise here I'm
suggesting with a fallback position of
v8 I suspect that highways aren't going
to be terribly bothered however a
counselor darn please
thank you chairman chairman I don't
think any of us could sit down and say
that what is there is very pretty and
that replacing it with pretty much
anything would be an improvement but not
a single member has mentioned the fact
that we have an adopted LDP we still
have a five year supply of housing land
and by granting this all we're going to
be doing is encouraging other people
that have got unused buildings to let
them fall into dilapidation and say well
we do we that we I just want them as a
house so absolutely I think this is
opening Pandora's box absolutely what is
there is an eyesore but I think we're on
very very dangerous very dangerous
ground here and as I said all we're
doing is driving a cart and horses to
our local development plan that we saw
fought so hard to get and I will be
supporting the officers recommendations
thank you thank you please Thank You
chairman and after senators then
councillor downs just stolen my thunder
obviously I wanted to highlight two
members is that this site is outside the
settlement boundary as we have regularly
as a council stated just because there
was no cultural building in a certain
level of disrepair this should not be a
material sedation of substantial way in
the determination of a plan application
the appearance of these buildings while
they may not be aesthetically high they
are above all nature
they normally have a lifespan that
obviously comes to an end at a certain
time and the loss of these buildings and
the degradation of them goes hand in
hand
and obviously they quite often fall away
any grant in a clan application needs to
be looked at at the lifetime at the
development this would be a number of
new dwellings in the countryside that
would go forward for a number of years
probably much greater than the remaining
Ciccio and that should be a
consideration as been explained the
site's outside boundary it's an
unsustainable location and if members do
grant planning permission for this this
will be a material consideration in
termination of future applications and
I'm sure members aware from seeing
appeal decisions we have won quite a few
where applications are just outside
sentiment boundary and inspect to say
that this does erode the rural character
even when there may be an agricultural
or building that appears our culture in
nature on-site so I think members just
need to be conscious of consistency and
impacts on future developments with this
one as well and once again that also
echoes for the employment aspects I know
members feel that the buildings are not
capable but not having evidence would
make it difficult for us to fight for
evidence in future applications because
assumptions should not be part of a
determination of a planning application
Thank You chairman they're not
brownfield this is very true Thank You
councillor dog no wrong councillor
Fleming then council white please Joe
Fleming Thank You chair I just wanted to
echo canceller Durham's concerns about
about this application yeah I think he's
right I think the danger is is that we
do open Pandora's box thank you Thank
You council white
sorry chairman I was there on phone call
and yeah no I just want to check what
the business use was because if it's
being used for business as the officers
are suggesting for refusing the
application oversee Caldera mention
brownfield and brownfield is recommended
towards residential and the other thing
is there is permitted development for
also from agricultural to residential so
I was curious what the use actually was
at the moment and because it's either
brownfield or and cultural and both of
which I thought were pretty much
permitted development through chairman I
can pick that for Cernik then the site
is not considered cultural but
notwithstanding that it would have to be
a prior approval and the buildings need
to be fit for post be used as a dwelling
and I don't think it's possible for the
council to argue the building's not fit
for employment with one hand and in with
the other hands inside their outfit for
conversion to residential as is not
withstanding that the point in relation
to brownfield or previously developed
land within the MPP F is that that
should be a consideration for
development outside current site that
doesn't mean it automatically needs to
be residential and to a certain extent
as we all know the MPP F is guidance and
the MPP F even accepts that the local
plan or the development plan is the
starting point for termination of
application and our policy does not
accept residential as a first point of
call for land outside a seventh boundary
there is a number of development types
that it does encourage and none of them
are residential and that is something
that inspectors have supported on
principle in numerous points as a policy
point there may be material situation
for against Incept ones but that's
irrelevant but as a point of principle
our policy does not accept residential
as a first consideration for previously
developed land Thank You chairman
theoretically it does accord with the
MPPs
but Molden don't like
don't agree with that part of the MPPs
in their policies so it easy effectively
compliant through chairman now to a
certain sent it starts that it should be
it's available for other types of
development it doesn't say it should be
residential it just says that would be
the first point to look at in
countryside but that doesn't say it
wouldn't be community doesn't say is
employment etc etc it's just a broad
brushstroke statement that is obviously
then drilled into through the imposition
of local authorities planning policies
that use it in a site-specific for their
own districts points Thank You chairman
thank you my concern is that we have
dilapidated bars all over the district
and that is not which I feel this is
clearly against anyone else to speak so
I put the recommendation as is no
amendments thank you Boehner could you
take a roll call with the body for
against and abstain
to refuse and long the offensive weapon
if it helps just use voice and not video
because a lot of us who are having
internet problems and all the other
recommendations reviews thank you so mr.
Fleming castle Fleming
cancel the Fleming have some Fleming are
you there just use audio only if it
helps should I come back to her in a
moment I think so yes Jarvis bought us
the keys against answerless idul against
cancer mrs. Thompson bar the
recommendation to refuse it's white
against mrs. Fleming I'm back sorry
about that
sorry where were we can you just this
for against abstain counsel mrs. Fleming
for the officers recommendation to Ricky
I'm for the officers recommendation to
refuse thank you
that's five for three against and no
abstentions thank you so that is
refusing line with the officers
recommendation now we have item eight
Barnes adjacent to Muslims farm tensed
Road curly again I have a submission to
read out applicant so could we have miss
Parkins
thank you caiman planning permission is
sought to regularize the change of use
of the agricultural buildings to two
dwellings the change of use in external
works to the single-story dwelling are
completed and this dwelling is under
occupation
however the works to the two-story
dwelling have not been completed the
regularization of the works are required
as the development was granted by their
prior approval application 15 0 1 0 9 6
this consent was granted subject to two
relevant conditions condition one
required the development to be completed
within a three-year period in addition
to required the development to be
carried out in complete accordance with
the approved draw
rings as the development is yet to be
completed the works have not been
carried out in accordance with condition
one furthermore there have been
amendments to the previously granted
scheme under the 2015 application
relating to the location of windows and
doors this is the location plan plan the
existing elevations these are the
proposed elevations so the floor plans
at the farms these booster floor plans
and here are photographs of the site the
current application is the full Planning
Commission and this is materially
different to that as a prior approval
application this is explained more in
section five point one of the offices
report this application is recommended
for refusal as the site lives outside of
the defined settlement boundary apply
the proposed development as a result of
the domestication of the site and
associated residential paraphernalia
with substantially older the open
character of the countryside and which
attract from an agricultural nature at
the site
furthermore the development would
provide insufficient private amenity
space interest has left the meeting and
did so start at the very start of the
presentation I have a submission to read
from Susan's the thern who's the
applicant as as before if I fail to read
it in two minutes that is my fault not
the applicant continued response two
reasons to refuse and response to reason
to the amenity space provided was in
line with the Kukla restrictions however
as shown on the location plan within the
Blue Line boundary there is space
surrounding us whereby we can extend the
amenity space allocated to the buildings
to the dwellings sorry the area of
private amenity space cited at point
five point six point one of the report
earlier
first to the private amines to space
situated to the rear of the dwellings
but if the area at the front was
included they would both comfortably
meet the hundred square meters for the
three-bedroom dwelling and 50 square
meters for the two-bedroom apologize
everyone back at the beginning of that
paragraph the area of private amenity
space sited at point five point six but
one of the report only refers to the
private community space situated to the
rear of the dwellings but if the area at
the front was included they would both
comfortably meet the hundred square
meters but the three-bedroom dwelling
and fifty square meters for the
two-bedroom running this pods the reason
three we would like to confirm that we
are more than happy to make the HRA
payment of two hundred and forty-four
pounds sixty and undertake - oh that's
it the recommendation is set out in the
report as follows is to refuse as
detailed in section 8 if any member
wishes to second that motion please
speak now anybody
yeah I will thank you that is seconded
by Councillor Dharam
I will invite members to make comments
or speak for or against this council
white is the other board member so if
you care to start please do if you'd
like to wait please thank you and yeah I
don't like this application because of
the way the ease that it's after the
work has been completed and after it's
been habited however all that aside I
don't to me it doesn't make much
difference for it's one or two dwellings
the permission was passed and but I'll
leave it to other members because I'm
kind of 50/50 on this one so I
personally don't have a problem with it
but I can understand why there is a
problem we do perhaps have to put our
foot down so I'll leave it to other
members and then what wait to decide on
their dues right I have kelps Alabam
foot and then council of dance on
council Mountain Pose
Thank You chairman a couple of questions
really I hope the officers can explain
about the amenity space in the report it
says that there is insufficient amenity
space and this is one of the reasons for
the refusal however in the report that
the Chairman read out it mentions using
a ministry space at the front of the
buildings to make it acceptable so I
would just like to clarify how that can
be done to include that space at the
front so
and also the landscape and boundary
treatment which you are recommending at
five six three I don't understand why
that is needed or how it's going to be
put in place so perhaps on the diagrams
or something you could explain about the
immunity space and about this landscape
and boundary treatments please okay
thank you sorry Joe and I don't have
anyone else in my house to answer the
phone
Thank You chairman for a point of
clarity the offices report deals with
the private community space that would
be allocated as part of the planning
application the applicant has indicated
that land to the front of the property
is also a million-two space but as
members are fully aware we as officers
and its decision makers they include
yourself are interested in the private
amenity that could be used for point bit
word the family that would be residing
in the dwelling so as often happens as
we know winner members of public quite
often flag up there may be parking areas
and areas to the front obviously that is
in private so it shouldn't be included
within the area that's why the office
report talks about the bit to the rear
in relation to the second point made by
councillor Bamford what that sound is
that if members were to look to approve
this game we just would consider it
officers consider it appropriate that
there should be a condition in relation
to boundary treatment because it hasn't
been indicated as parts application how
that would be provided and officers are
conscious of the war location we would
want to make sure it's an appropriate
forum a boundary treatment for its
setting thank you chairman to explain
some of the technicalities on this would
this be a good time or if you rather
hear what the members have to say as the
case officer cost case officer explained
this is a slightly complex matter and I
think
counselor White's or nodded her head to
that point as well in 2015 a prior
approval application was granted one of
the conditions for that is that planning
permission must be or the development
must be completed within three years
which would have been in December 2009 I
think that
since then council has been obviously
how it was saved a complaint in relation
to the enforcement case that has been
opened as this wasn't completed and
therefore they applicant hasn't complied
with that condition and as mr. Perkins
explained there's also a condition in
relation to the appearance to be done in
quantity approved plans which hasn't
been undertaken therefore a planning
application was required to recognize
this formal development counselors will
be aware that the fallback position when
it is permitted development allowance is
a material consideration but the weight
to be given to it needs to be reflected
by the likelihood of this permission
actually being implemented as explained
due to the the permission not being done
in country to prove plans or within the
time there is no prior approval for that
position because work has commenced so
that has fallen away so I would advise
members that the fallback position is a
limited way in determining this
application which then just brings us to
the consideration of a planning
application for dwellings in the
countryside and the principle of
development members will be aware that
we have refused numbers of applications
around this area outside certain
boundary and because it is not
sustainable location my advice would be
to be very wary of conscious of this
when considering this application
because grant in planning permission for
the dwellings obviously would be a
material consideration in any future
applications for dwellings in this area
[Music]
is very useful well we're here again
aren't we like miss white one thing that
gets up my nose quite a lot is
retrospective particularly when people
have tried to bend the rules whether
that was intentional or not it's not for
us to say but as mr. leader said you
know it is not in a sustainable location
we have an adopted local development
plan he's outside the development
boundary
we have to be consistent and I'm very
sorry but I support the officers
recommendations thank you
I have counsel and then counselor white
and moment after that Thank You chairman
yeah my view is that this is a
retrospective it's it's yeah there's
perhaps been some oversight and it was
passed before so therefore I would go
against the officers recommendation and
we should approve these these dwellings
thank you I think I might get mr. Lee
back in this could explain it but it was
a different kind of application before
and the conditions that that haven't
been satisfied so in case I haven't got
that right or it needs elaborating thank
you Thank You chairman yeah to be honest
I probably didn't explain that very well
in the last spill the application that
was looked at previously is a prior
approval process which is basically a
form of permitted development that is
allowed through the permitted
development legislation with a number of
restrictions that does not look at
things such as openness to the location
sustainability or our policies it looks
at whether the building is physically
capable of being altered and whether
it's been agricultural in nature and a
couple of other points such as
contamination obviously that is a
consideration but as I explained
previously the chances of this being had
to be brought forward is now not
possible so therefore as a fullback
position should be given the limited why
not so members can't give it any weight
but it should be given white that is
appropriate for the ability for it to be
implemented which in this case obviously
isn't we're now looking at planning
application which means that we can
consider all of the various material
considerations such as our policies such
as government guidelines etc rather than
just a very strict very limited number
of categories and therefore for example
with the receipt the second item that we
looked at today for the application
where previous outline had been granted
him this was as though there was a
second one that we were looking at this
is very different in that respects as
this is not one application
to 2015 and a new application being in
front of us this is a permitted
development application that's falling
away and now for the first time the
council is looking at full plans it's a
full permission I hope I've been a
little bit clearer Thank You chairman
yes thank you thank you refusing this
because of the location because there
were two appeals I think last year or
the year before one of them was for a
house I think called Sunnyside which was
just opposite where the old pub used to
be that's now a house covered Lane
without either and I actually supported
that one for a 2-bit among low it got
turned down act committee and then went
through appeal and that was turned down
because of unsustainable location where
is the inspector fennec was sustainable
and then on the other side of the road a
bit further along nearest the barns at
muslins farm there was another
application which I didn't support which
was for removal condition and build
another house and I didn't support that
because the driveway was right on the
corner and I didn't think it was safe
but that also got approved at appeal or
allowed to appeal so I would yeah I
would be wary obviously with location
because it's only probably a hundred
metres or so from both of those it might
be a little bit longer see when you
drive it it seems longer but I do think
there's we can't use if we do refuse it
we cannot use the location being
unsuitable for residential because we've
lost that twice at appeal Thank You mr.
chairman officer bring members
attentions to paragraph or section 5.7
of the officers with pole yep that is
page 61 I've got and the officer he goes
into some detail relation to the
sustainable location of the site and
also
talks about a number of Appeals such as
the one of 2015 at tree Lord where the
peer was allowed but that was prior to
us having a five year land supply which
obviously is a very big difference to
where we are now of the applicant and in
relation to sunny Court which was 2017
application which is dealt with in quite
a bit of detail by the case officer in
five point seven point five and two
summary says while there were
similarities been the above-mentioned
application the current application for
the barns adjacent to ma students farm
sunny cut it's a proxy two hundred
meters closer to settlement boundary of
pearly whereby the patent of element is
significantly different to that of the
application so I further my application
should be determined and its own merit
so I think that you know the officers
have considered those but do not
consider that they are directly
comparable and therefore shouldn't be
weigh in favor of this application Thank
You Sharon thank you that's very helpful
I have no one else to speak so burner
could we please have a roll call and a
vote on the when we are voting on the
offices recommendation to the report
thank you and as usual it's four against
abstain councillor Bamford for master
mrs. Fleming caso Jarvis oh thank you
how's the keys for Sybil against hostile
mrs. Thompson Oh as to miss white I've
decided to go against really because I
don't believe that the lease is the
sustainable location is an issue so
that's made my mind up for me thank you
okay that's fine I for
or two against no abstentions thank you
both for the officers recommendation and
so on keep things as brisk as we can
that would be great thank you out of
nine land Southwest
anyway sorry
that's the Thompson we just posed to
make sure accounts of Fleming's back in
the capsule Fleming can you just give us
the heads-up when you're back because
some that's what's been correctly
pointed out I shouldn't I don't want to
carry on without you because then you
can't vote
oh I've got your back as well I'm not
well and let's just do them let's just
try again is it possible to how do you
think anybody
she's on a bit is showing us unavailable
at the moment and she's trying to cool
it connect okay thank you
are you having any luck no not not yet
um it's not saying unavailable at least
so I'm about to have a husband sorry I'm
in a public meeting so having to look
you don't get stopped first mrs. Fleming
should play the pill I'm so sorry Jane
but we kind of have to carry on if we
can't get you back in again that's very
unfortunate
yeah she's calling ah I'm calling game
looks like tonight me genius
I'm afraid is still showing just as
calling so I'm not quite sure where the
driver
hello it's Mario nice talk
aha
okay well give it a couple of minutes
then I really don't want to exclude you
okay thank you bye
she's swapping Reuters to a 4G one and
maybe with us in a couple of minutes
which I'm gonna have to time pretty
exactly really good
Oh
mmm I think we might have to carry on
without huh
okay so Miss Matthews if you could get
the get the presentation up some miracle
capsule Fleming appears thank you thank
you storage barn a related access road
at land Southwest thoughtful farm in
white bread stead location plan outlines
designed in red same and [ __ ] slightly
just to these are the existing
iterations provided for the building the
post elevations reference in the report
is made to a previous scheme which it
was refused permission and subsequently
dismissed on appeal these the elevations
for that scheme photos of the site which
aren't 100 sent up to date and some lady
from last year but some more recent is
made to some and supporting the
information that's been submitted though
in terms of the extent of land holding
this is the drawing that has been
submitted and the red arrow points to
the location of the application site
within that land holding
presence is also made to drawings
narrow points to that and this is
another plan for in the application site
actually on this story
so offices the proposal previously
refused so there's no justifiable need
for the the barn and the building itself
causing thank you very much second did
Thank You counselor down that seconded
so we are debating the officers
recommendation to refuse I suspect out
some keys like starters office I called
again that's your option counsel you can
begin or not as you choose yes
I've called DC and I've called it in
before for the applicant as you all well
aware of this I have have you seen the
letter that Stanford sent out plate of
the graves I've been issued I certainly
did other members probably haha yeah
I've just thought to comment on he has
altered it to what the the appeal
decision said without with the materials
I still believe that it is needed for
the storage of agricultural stuff
because as we all know here's a
landowner and he asked all sees anything
has got high and we all know as well if
you don't lock it up bolt it down it it
tends to disappear nowadays
unfortunately at the time we live in
can't really argue anymore said
agricultural building there's a building
there now it will tidy the place up
nor their I suppose in fairness I did
cart down there before this act we can
owned it when it was an apple farm and
it was a busy apple farm and obviously
the time when apples repeat so the
building has always been there and I
think it justifies what has been said by
pay degree from Stanford and that's all
I've got to say on it thank you I
disagree with the councillors and a lot
proposed it should be passed if I'm
going to do that
thank you okay I have council of white
and then councillor Fleming who although
she can't focus missed the very
beginning of the presentation she is
able to speak so we'll come to her after
council of white council I please thank
you madam chairman I mean I just like to
say that in line with counts the keys
and this came before us previously I
actually supported it the last time if
I'm right I think it's a bit smaller
than it was last time and I think it is
a useful building I don't have a problem
with it at all I mean the site's a mess
and I think it's actually improved where
it is thank you Fleming Thank You chair
it's unfortunate I wanted to ask the
officers that was at what sort of
evidence they usually require for this
type of application I see in the papers
that they feel that the applicants agent
hasn't provided enough information what
would normally be supplied for example
entitlement statement from the rural
payments agency is a you know piece of
pet useful document provides Land
Holdings acreage so do they have that or
what what's missing thank you mr.
Matthews you want to pick up you want me
to I can't do yes fine use them okay
thank you one of the issues with this
application is that and I'm wondering
would normally expect is for the the
size and position of the building to be
justified so you could they've said that
they've got certain acreage of of land
but would normally expect to say
information for example we take its tons
of hay off the land each year and
therefore we need this no volume space
to store it so it the details would be
submitted all in office if you're a bit
vague the other issue that they picked
up is the those drawings that I put up
on screen earlier the the land that has
been included in the land holding
includes land that is not agricultural
land and and the agricultural land
drawing that means meteor doesn't
include the site as part of the
agricultural agricultural land though
there's some discrepancies there and in
order to make uh sort of a sound for
case we don't feel about that has that
has been done by by the agent that is
acting for the for the owner and and
that the part of the appeal the
inspector also concluded that the
evidence on the need for the building of
that size had it hadn't been made so the
new application there's a bit more
information but in offices you haven't
gone far enough and maybe the applicant
could make a case but hasn't been able
to do so as part of the current
application thank you thank you
oh geez wants to come back at the end is
there anyone who wishes to speak more
then counts the keys the keys Your Honor
I haven't anyone else come back
councillor Fleming if you really would
like to go at the very end I need to put
counselor Fleming in first is that
Alright go ahead mrs. Fleming Thank You
councillor Keyes thank you Jeff mmm yes
counselor Keyes mentioned the applicants
agents letter to counselors at the
beginning and I saw that the maps
provided were outlined in blue whereas
the agent referred to them being
outlined in red and it would be my
understanding that the rural payments
agency do outline in red not blue so I
just wanted some clarification as to
whether the colour had been changed or
was it blue when submitted just from the
officers thank you Oh mr. Lee anybody my
understanding would be that the lines of
color is appropriate for planning
application in blue all read as part of
the planning application is has any
particular relevance the they're just
for illustration really to show the land
that they say is part of agreement so
but their planning application is red
and blue is quite significant and
application sites have to be outlined in
red and land adjacent land owned by the
applicant outlined in blue and I don't
don't think there's any particular
significance or problem it necessarily
and in the way
being used on the the letter that was
sent around to members thank you okay
thank you message but I think that was
just a communication but did you want to
speak no thank you right I have
counseled the keys would like to round
up and then mister knee and then we'll
both Thank You counsel please right can
we heard now right I think we all live
in the rural area so we all know when
you buy old straw high it needs to be
kept dry certain members that keep
horses know there's a necessity he does
keep horses we all know the landowner
and the applicant its security keep
animals straw through whether he gets
one bile or four thousand bales off of
it I think it's neither here nor there
there is adequate land that needs to be
cut for high that needs to be stored in
droid and the machinery needs to be
secured as I said before it all just get
taken so and he's adjusted by the letter
from Peter Liguori they've altered the
building materials it's it's in it's a
barn in the countryside and that is all
I have to say and I would like to
recommend that this is for approval
again place okay thank you counselor
keys I mean aren't my reading of the
inspectors with dismissal of the appeal
is that it's not appropriate I have a
bomb here so kept mr. Lee
mr. Ling Thank You Chancellor my
technology was having some problems yeah
obviously highlights members that this
is an application that has been
previously looked at by the council and
has gone to appear when dismissed
personally I don't consider
professionally that the application has
changed significantly and the offices
report does highlight that and as the
chairman just stated a real concern of
the inspector in my opinion was that the
appropriateness of providing a cultural
barn on a site that County currently
doesn't evidence be used for
agricultural need and why would it be
appropriate to put that here and counts
the case just said it's not here nor
there whether there's one bale of hay or
however many bales of hay actually that
is a very important material
consideration the need for development
within the wool countryside should be
evidenced and as officers as Miss
Matthews explained and the officers
report exceed uhz we do not consider
that that has been provided and this is
only slightly an increase in information
as what was covered by the time of the
previous appeal when the inspector did
not consider it was acceptable so I
would just advise members to be very
conscious of the previous decision the
summary that is enough to support what
the inspector said and the inspectors
decision to dismiss the previous appeal
Thank You chairman Thank You mr. Lee
which is two four against or abstain on
the officers recommendation to the fuse
Thank You chair Custer Banford for Asli
damn what a suit miss Fleming doesn't
count I'm afraid oh of course
casteau Jarvis or pass the keys against
Hospice it'll for mrs. Thompson Oh
it's white girls okay so that's five or
two against no abstentions thank you so
that is who's denying the officers
recommendation item ten on the agenda is
other items of business the chairman of
the committee decides an urgent there
are none I'm going to close the meeting
members and officers thank you for your
contributions this afternoon I'm drawing
this meeting to close at 2:50 as the
meeting is now closed
members are advised not to enter into
any further discussion on this forum
because you're on YouTube and to please
leave the meeting promptly thank you